Germany now says it will for the first
time send heavy anti-aircraft to weapon
systems to Ukraine to help fight off
Russia's Invasion the decision follows
weeks of criticism at home and from
Ukraine defense minister Christina
lambrecht made the announcement at a U.S
led meeting of defense and military
leaders at Ramstein Air Base here in
Germany
U.S Air Base in Ramstein Germany this is
where the United States and its allies
pledged new packages of ever heavier
weapons for Ukraine during a meeting on
Tuesday that was hosted by U.S defense
secretary Lloyd Austin
buddy thanks for uh we don't have any
time to waste
the briefings today laid out clearly why
the coming weeks will be so crucial for
Ukraine
so we've got to move at the speed of War
and I know that all the leaders
leave today
more resolved than ever to support
Ukraine
in his fight against Russian aggression
the day kicked off with a surprise in a
notable policy shift Germany which had
been criticized for refusing to send
heavy weapons to Ukraine announced it
would now send gippat anti-aircraft
systems
we've made the decision that it's now
important to support anti-aircraft
defense that can be done with a good
part and is exactly what's on the list
of what Ukraine needs and that is what
we coordinated with others are now
making possible we'll continue doing
this
not everyone in Berlin welcomed the
decision
problematic Germany doesn't even have
enough military equipment for itself in
the case of poutine totally losing
control
I think it's important I also think that
what the German government is doing is
good
but I am also not sure if offering
weapons is actually going to stop the
war
I didn't like the degree of hesitancy in
the end I would actually be four
aggressive weapons so heavier machinery
is
in his closing remarks Austin said the
Gathering between the U.S and its allies
will not be the last once a month
they'll need to discuss Ukraine's
defense needs to help them fight the
Russian invasion
let's get more from DW's political Chief
political editor Michaela kufner welcome
Michaela so what is behind this German
U-turn what's prompted it an internal
struggle within the governing Coalition
which lasted for weeks and in the end
saw Chancellor Schultz and his social
Democrats still not wanting to deliver
those heavy weapons to Ukraine while the
free Democrats and the greens had
already been calling for exactly that at
the same time they all said that they're
on the same page but they clearly
weren't and here we now see what is a
second small turnaround really because
internally here in Germany this is seen
as a paradigm shift the delivery of
heavy weapons into a war zone that is a
first and it crosses what previously was
seen as a red line here in Germany
externally particularly when you look at
those Eastern Partners it's Germany
finally being in sync with the rest of
Western Airlines right so what pushed
them over the edge
it really was the internal pressure as
well
um that the free Democrats the greens
wanted to see their Chancellor
strike not just a different tone but
actually show that with action and at
the same time we're seeing this external
pressure the Americans calling this
meeting on German soil at a U.S military
base if you wanted to be part of the
West really
um this was the moment to change and
change direction here and as we heard in
the report this meeting is to become a
regular event yes and I think there is a
very profound message in this
um we've had a lot of debates in the
past over who is the West well it was
the West sitting down around the table
right just NATO not well that's the
important thing it was exactly not NATO
countries it was it's a much broader
um set of countries it is the West it's
liberal democracies standing together
standing up for Ukraine NATO still wants
to and vows to stay out of this being a
clearly just a defensive Union and um
here these are the Willing States the
states willing to stand up for Ukraine
but making this monthly just manifest
the impression we're getting
increasingly this will last not just
months but potentially years right and
how damaging has a Chancellor Schultz's
perceived foot dragging been for Germany
standing well he started off pretty fast
three days after
Ukraine was invaded by Russia it was the
German chancellor who declared its
height and vendor a new era and then he
was not just perceived to be dragging
his heels he was not willing to go down
that Avenue of heavy weapons now Germany
seemed to do exactly what it vowed not
to do once again
um in this mounting conflict and it does
raise some question marks over who
really leads in Europe who is the true
leader
um and at the same time it is actually
done quite a bit of damage to the trust
that eastern states those Eastern
countries the baltics have in the
Germans okay thank you for that rdw's
Chief political editor Michaela
let's talk about this further with uh
valter fightinger who is a former
Brigadier General of Austria's uh forces
he's now president of the center for
strategic analysis that's a Vienna based
think tanker welcome to DW
um let's talk about the weapons that
Germany is now promising what sort of
difference will these gephard
anti-aircraft tanks make
I do not expect an immediate effect on
the ground on the Battleground by
delivering heavy weapons from Germany
but in the long run I've been say longer
run and think about the few months for
example you can have a strong impact on
the capacities of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces because the danger from the air
coming from Russian Fighters and attack
helicopters is very intensive so having
some weapons against it will make a
change
and the the the clamor from Ukraine for
um uh for air defenses from from NATO
countries that seems to have calmed down
now does that does that mean they've
given up uh on that because NATO has
said no to it
now it is still on place I would say and
it is of highest importance for the
survival of the tank forces for example
from the Ukrainian side because the
danger from the EA is so high so they
need it really very importantly
and and so how well equipped let's talk
about the Ukrainian side and how well
equipped is ukrainia's uh Ukraine's Army
two months into this war
I think it's a question that never can
nobody can answer really exactly but
what we see is the effect on the ground
Ukrainian forces are still able to stop
Russian assaults assaults and they are
still able to maneuver in a certain
extent in a certain area so they are
withstanding on a very high level I
would say and that is in a huge
advantage of the delivered weapon size
here really because they got a lot of
anti-tank weapons and anti-air weapons
and that makes a difference because now
they are able to defend on a higher
level and they are not running out of
weapons and ammunition
so this is a battle that seems to have
exposed Russia as something of a phantom
superpower as it were because the
expectation was that that they would
obliterate Ukraine and clearly we
presume that there are many more Russian
forces in reserve so what's going on
here is Russia choosing not to throw
everything at this conflict or or is
Russia actually doing that and still
coming out um not as well as we expect
as many analysts say Russia is throwing
a lot of of troops that they have
available towards run towards Ukraine so
it is not the size I would say it is
more the capacity on the ground to act
and to act in a very coordinated way so
many people say already that the force
and the strength of the Russian forces
was overestimated and I agree to a
certain extent
in his meeting with the UN Secretary
General today a Russian foreign minister
Sergey lavrov said he had complained
about the West effectively trying to
establish an alternative organization to
the UN now we hear that the United
States is convening a monthly meeting of
defense and military leaders from 40 odd
countries to coordinate weapons supplies
and strategy Mr lavrov seems to have a
point doesn't he
I would say it is a change of
argumentation from the Russian side
because from the very first moment they
neglected to call it the war they call
it a military operation the answer said
they will focus on the Thomas only and
the attacked Kiev the capital and so on
and so forth so I would say it is a very
adaptive argumentation from the Russian
side according to the situation on the
ground okay good talking to you that's
uh very clear thank you so much for
joining us uh valta are fighting
thank you